[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
Bundeskanzler Scholz formulierte es
kürzlich so wir brauchen Halbleiter sehr
viele Halbleiter Halbleiter und nochmals
Halbleiter wir brauchen sie aber wir
produzieren sie selber kaum Halbleiter
stecken in diesen winzigen Chips die
praktisch überall verbaut werden nicht
zuletzt in Autos die Bundesregierung
lässt es sich nun viel kosten
ausländische Chiphersteller anzulocken
auch wenn daraus dann keine deutschen
Unternehmen werden wenigstens
produzieren sie dann hier ein
Subventionswettlauf der nicht
unumstritten ist knapp 10 Milliarden
sollen an den US-Konzernen Intel fließen
damit er sich in Magdeburg ansiedelt und
5 Milliarden an den taiwanesischen Chip
Hersteller TSMC
dessen Vorstand verkündete heute die
Entscheidung ein Werk in Dresden zu
bauen Steffi Moritz berichtet
weniger überraschend eher lange wartet
kam die Nachricht dass sich der
taiwanesische Chiphersteller TSMC in
Dresden ansiedeln und damit zum ersten
Mal Milliarden schwer Richtung Europa
aufbrechen wird im Silicon 6 Uni in
Dresden schon jetzt Europas größter
mikroelektronik-standort ist der Jubel
groß
ist der Lohn einer harten Arbeit über
drei Jahrzehnte Investitionen in
Mikroelektronik aufbauend auf dem was in
der DDR schon entstanden ist das
Vertrauen bei den großen Unternehmen
Bosch NXP Infineon die sehr dafür
geworben haben bei diesem taiwanesischen
Technologieführer kommt hierher hier ist
der beste Platz für die Produktion und
das ist natürlich schön weil daraus sich
unglaublich viel entwickeln wird für die
kommenden Jahre und Jahrzehnte
Halbleiterwerk soll gemeinsam mit Bosch
Infineon und NXP gebaut werden die mit
jeweils 10% an dem tsmc-projekt
beteiligt sind und seit Jahren in
Dresden schon produzieren Spatenstich
für die Pep soll Anfang nächsten Jahres
sein Eröffnung 2027 Deutschland
entwickelt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich zu
dem großen Standort für die Halbleiter
Produktion in Europa das ist wichtig für
die Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres
europäischen Kontinents und es ist
wichtig ganz besonders natürlich auch
für die Zukunftsfähigkeit Deutschlands
insgesamt wild MC 10 Milliarden Euro
investieren der Bund hat die Hälfte als
Subvention zugesagt ein enormer Zuschuss
nicht unumstritten
die Politik muss manchmal eine Wette auf
die Zukunft eingehen und das betrifft
vor allem Schlüsselindustrien Geld geben
subventionieren das alleine reicht nicht
der Staat muss eine gute Infrastruktur
bereitstellen Fachkräfte müssen da sein
die Regulierung Bürokratie muss so sein
dass Unternehmen auch investieren können
doch klar ist auch weltweit wird die
Halbleiterbranche noch in ganz anderen
Dimensionen zu pensioniert und Europa
muss versuchen bei der Chip-Produktion
unabhängiger vor allem von China zu
werden die Subventionen sind deswegen
notwendig weil wir erstens teurer sind
als andere Regionen weil der Wettbewerb
an anderen Standorten nicht fair geführt
wird und weil wir drittens bei einigen
Bereichen diese Technologie nicht mehr
haben die SMC dagegen beherrscht die
fortschrittlichsten
Fertigungstechnologien der Welt kann die
Chips mit den kleinsten Strukturgrößen
herstellen
in Dresden sollen vor allem erstmal die
dringend benötigten Chips für die
Automobilindustrie produziert werden
deren Nachfrage soll sich in den
nächsten Jahren voraussichtlich
verdoppeln bis verdreifachen großes
Problem bis dahin die Fachkräfte etwa
2000 sucht der teckige
tausende weiteres sollen in der Umgebung
entstehen extra dafür wird in Sachsen
eine chip-akademie gegründet um
international auszubilden aber
Voraussetzung für all das ist noch die
Zustimmung aus Brüssel dass die 5
Milliarden Euro Zuschuss auch fließen
dürfen und das kann dauern
und dazu noch die Nachfrage an unsere
Wirtschaftsredaktion Valerie Haller die
Bundesregierung dürfte über diese
Anwerbung doch share sehr speziell auch
die Interessen der deutschen
Automobilindustrie im Blick haben ja
genau und das kann man auch an der Liste
der Partner ablesen die sich am Bau der
neuen Fabrik verteidigen beteiligen
darunter eben Bosch und Infineon beides
Zulieferer der Automobilindustrie ja
welche Auswirkungen chipmangel haben
kann das mussten Autokonzerne ja
schmerzlich während der corona-pandemie
erfahren da standen teilweise die Bänder
still weil die Lieferung aus Asien aus
blieben aber Chip ist nicht gleich Chip
damals und auch heute noch fehlen vor
allem die einfacheren Varianten die
beispielsweise für den Fensterheber
gebraucht werden in Dresden aber werden
Chips gebaut die künftig vor allem fürs
autonome fahren und die Elektromobilität
wichtig werden Dresden Chips sind für
die Autoindustrie Moment also noch ein
bisschen Zukunftsmusik aber in ein paar
Jahren schon könnte sie einer ihrer
besten Kunden werden danke schön Valerie
es geht jedenfalls nicht nur um Chips
das Thema wollen wir noch vertiefen mit
unserer Partnerin Diana Zimmermann in
Taiwan in Taipei Diana welches Interesse
hat ein taiwanesischer Chip Hersteller
daran nach Dresden zu gehen
TSMC ist eines der erfolgreichsten
Unternehmen der Welt die können gut
rechnen und sehen dass sich auf dem
europäischen Markt in Sachen Halbleiter
gerade sehr viel tut gerade in
Deutschland auch wir haben ja neulich
erst die Ankündigung bekommen das Intel
dort sehr stark investieren wird hier
SMC möchte einen Teil davon abbekommen
und die Subventionen von denen wir ja
schon gehört haben bis zu 5 Milliarden
sind dann natürlich auch sehr attraktiv
die SMC hat auch schon früher
international investiert es gibt
Fabriken in Singapur und auch zwei in
China allerdings ist doch auffällig dass
die letzten Investitionen die letzten
drei großen Investitionen alle in
Staaten der G7 gegangen sind Metall
waren freundschaftlich verbundene
Staaten es liegt also der Gedanke nahe
dass diese wirtschaftlichen Allianzen
auch die politische Allianz Metall waren
stärken soll dann hat aber einiges zu
bieten also die Bedeutung die dieses
kleine Land weltpolitisch für bzw
weltwirtschaftliche der Chip Herstellung
hat ist ja gar nicht zu unterschätzen da
ist Teil man ja wirklich ein Riese
absolut ohne die Chips wäre Taiwan
wahrscheinlich noch weniger Leuten
bekannt als diese kleine demokratische
Insel die versucht sich gegen den
Übergriff von China zu wehren die
Halbleiterindustrie ist hier ganz
zentral sie ist staatlich gefördert und
ausgebaut worden und ist inzwischen so
dass eben die ganze Welt von diesen
Halbleiterchips aus Taiwan abhängt und
zwar vor allen Dingen von den ganz ganz
kleinen die in Handys und Computern
verbaut werden diejenigen die jetzt in
Dresden verbaut werden das sind sehr
viel größere die sich eigentlich vor
allen Dingen für die Autoindustrie
eignen aber bei diesen ganz kleinen
Chips geht eben gar nichts mehr ohne
Taiwan und das macht die Bedeutung
Taiwans international sehr groß und ist
eine Art Schutzschild für dieses von
China bedrohte Land also eine Art
Lebensversicherung dass der Westen allen
voran die USA ein Interesse daran haben
teilweise zu schützen eben auch aus
ökonomischen eigenen Interesse
ganz genau so muss man das sehen
Taiwan verlässt sich nicht darauf dass
die USA und Europa das demokratische
teilwand Schützen mit dem sie in
Verbindung sind nicht richtig in
diplomatischen Verbindungen da steht
China davor China beharrt darauf dass es
eine ein China-Politik seiner der
Staaten gibt mit denen es in Verbindung
steht und akzeptiert eben nicht sondern
droht damit ist ein womöglich gewaltsam
einzunehmen sollte es zum Krieg kommen
mit Taiwan und davon gehen viele aus
dass das nicht mehr eine Frage ist ob
das passiert sondern nur wann es
passiert dann ist dieser
Halbleiterindustrie natürlich erstens
etwas dass ich die Streitenden Mächte
gerne unter den Nagel reißen würden
andererseits ist es auch so dass wir
gerade hier hören sollte es zum Krieg
mit China kommen und sollte es so
aussehen als wenn China diesen Krieg
gewonnen dann wäre es wohl so dass
Taiwan oder die USA die
Halbleiterindustrie Taiwans zerstören
werden damit sie eben nicht China nicht
in die Hände hält so groß ist die
Bedeutung der ist von Sie hier in diesem
Land
die andere Mann danke schön für die
Analyse
ohne Chips jedenfalls auch keine
Digitalisierung und das ist ja nicht das
einzige Thema bei dem Deutschland
hinterher hängt weil jahrelang zu wenig
investiert wurde wie Mobilfunknetze oder
beliebtes dauert Thema Schienennetz und
Flotte der deutschen Banken wenn man
Straßen entlasten wird man die
Schienenwege ausbauen müssen nur neue
Kunden anzulocken das wird wohl nicht
reichen mit dem deutschland-ticket das
vor genau 100 Tagen gestartet wurde
wurden die Regionalzüge zwar voller aber
nicht pünktlicher und da wo es gar kein
Angebot in öffentlichen Nahverkehr gibt
gab es logischerweise auch wenig
Interesse am neuen Ticket Martin Niessen
zieht eine erste Bilanz
wie würden in Schleswig-Holstein 30 km
nordwestlich von Hamburg
600 Einwohner von denen kaum jemand ein
deutschlandticket hat wozu auch
ich habe keins
ich wäre kein Anschluss habe das
bräuchtet
eine vernünftige Verkehrsanbindung die
nicht nur viermal am Tag fährt der
kleine Ort ist vom öffentlichen
Nahverkehr quasi abgeschnitten
das einzige was wir hier haben wo wir
schon richtig stolz drauf sind ist ein
Schulbus der aber fährt nur ein paar Mal
am Tag und weder am Wochenende noch in
den Schulferien damit das
deutschland-ticket auf dem Land ein
Erfolg werden kann müsse das Angebot
ausgebaut werden fordert der Vorsitzende
der Verkehrsministerkonferenz der Länder
NRWs Verkehrsminister griechischer es
muss qualitativ besser werden die Züge
müssen verlässlicher werden und es muss
natürlich auch quantitativ besser werden
wir brauchen mehr Züge mehr Verbindungen
mehr Vertaktung auch insgesamt mehr
öffentlichen Verkehr gerade auch im
ländlichen Raum ein völlig anderes Bild
in Hamburg Bahnen und Busse fahren im
Minutentakt und sind prophevoll auch
außerhalb des Berufsverkehrs und trotz
Sommerferien hier ist das
deutschland-ticket einem im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes voller Erfolg bei
Einheimischen und Touristen
gleichermaßen es ermöglicht mir dass ich
günstiger zur Arbeit komme jetzt im
Urlaub dass man halt vor allem in
Hamburg einfach so alle hoffentlich
nutzen kann und so wartet der Hamburger
Verkehrsverbund mit ziemlich
eindrucksvollen Zahlen auf wir haben
mittlerweile über 253.000 Neukundinnen
und Kunden und damit insgesamt über
960.000 Abonnenten und Abonnenten im HVV
deutlich mehr als je zuvor bundesweit
verkaufte sich das 49 Euro teure Ticket
bislang mehr als 11 Millionen Mal aber
eben vor allem in großen Städten und
Ballungsräumen für eine größere
Akzeptanz auf dem Land braucht es
Milliardeninvestitionen in die
Infrastruktur die bundländer und
Kommunen zusätzlich zu den Milliarden
Subventionen für das deutschlandticket
stemmen müssen im Herbst gehe ich davon
aus dass wir dann also eine nachtelang
Messe haben werden mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten und den
Bundeskanzler wo dann also gefragt wird
wo soll eigentlich das Geld herkommen
oder feststellen dass das 49 Euro Ticket
gar nicht seriös finanziert ist und das
deutschland-ticket mehr ist als nur ein
Sommerferien Phänomen muss sich auch in
Hamburg noch zeigen wenn all die
Touristen weg sind die jetzt die elbphär
en Nutzen für eine Hafenrundfahrt ohne
Zusatzkosten
in der Ukraine hat es ja wieder schwere
Bombardierungen gegeben damit beginnen
jetzt die nachrichtenheits ja die Zahl
der Opfer des russischen raketenangriffs
auf die Stadt burgrowsk hat sich weiter
erhöht die Ukraine berichtet inzwischen
dass sieben Menschen getötet und mehr
als 80 verletzt wurden und sie wirft
Russland dort auch erneut einen Angriff
gezielt auf Rettungskräfte vor die
beiden gestern in einem Wohngebiet
eingeschlagenen Raketen seinem Abstand
von etwa 40 Minuten auf das selbe Ziel
abgefeuert worden mit dem zweiten
Beschuss habe die russische Seite
bewusst die Helfer getroffen die nach
dem ersten Einschlag dort waren
die italienische Regierung hat eine
Sondersteuer bei bankgewinnen
angekündigt der Gesetzentwurf dazu soll
nun ins Parlament kommen der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident
Salvini sagte im Zuge der
Zinsentwicklung würden hohe Gewinne
gemacht die Steuereinnahmen sollen für
Entlastungen von Haushalten und
Unternehmen verwendet werden
die Inflation in Deutschland hat sich im
Juli etwas abgeschwächter Statistische
Bundesamt bestätigte die erste Schätzung
einer Jahresteuerungsrate von 6,2% nach
6,4% im Juni besonders stark stiegen im
Juli im Jahresvergleich die Preise für
Nahrungsmittel um 11%
der Chef des Beamtenbundes Silberbach
warnt vor den Folgen von Personalmangel
im öffentlichen Dienst die Bevölkerung
werde das in den kommenden Jahren noch
stärker zu spüren bekommen den Zeitungen
der Funke Mediengruppe sagte Silberbach
wenn man bei Digitalisierung und
Bürokratieabbau nicht endlich
Vorankommen werde der bevorstehende
Personalmangel Bearbeitungsfristen
verlängern Betreuungsschlüssel
verschlechtern und die staatliche
Leistungsfähigkeit insgesamt signifikant
Schwächen
in Portugal bekämpfen Einsatzkräfte
weiterhin zahlreiche Waldbrände zu 15
größeren feuerkämen neue Brände hinzu
und das bei Temperaturen von zum Teil
über 40 Grad laut Zivilschutz sind mehr
als 900 Feuerwehrleute allein im
Südwesten des Landes im Einsatz wo ein
brandherz war stabilisiert werden konnte
es aber immer noch zwei kritische Punkte
geben bereits mehr als 1.400 Menschen
wurden in Sicherheit gebracht
die einen fliehen vor Feuer die anderen
vor Hochwassern in Slowenien wird nach
und nach das ganze Ausmaß der Zerstörung
sichtbar wer eine solche Flutkatastrophe
schon mal selbst erlebt hat wie hier in
Deutschland die Bewohner des aartals der
weiß was die Slowenen jetzt erleiden der
Schock und die Angst die einem noch in
den Knochen sitzen das Entsetzen im
Angesicht von Schlammmassen und den
Trümmern die zuvor ein Zuhause waren
Wolf Christian Ulrich berichtet für uns
aus Slowenien
hier war eine Straße jetzt ist hier nur
noch der Fluss das Traumhaus am Ufer
abbruchreif 240 Häuser hier in der
Gegend von letusch haben die Fluten
zerstört jetzt der Versuch Ordnung ins
Chaos zu bringen bis hier stand das
Wasser zeigt vielen Lechner
das Wasser stand so hoch dass wir mit
boten gerettet wurden das Haus ist jetzt
unbewohnbar wir haben alles ausgeräumt
Tante Franziska bringt Stärkung
wenigstens kann ich so helfen sagt sie
und später gebe ich Geld es ist toll wie
viele Leute hier sind damit hätte ich
nicht gerechnet
die Männer mit den Schaufeln greifen
dankbar zu sogar zwei Urlauberinnen aus
Deutschland haben sich spontan
eingefunden um den Flut Opfern zu helfen
wir waren in der Gegend und dann haben
wir halt alles gesehen und haben uns
entschieden
[Musik]
uns anzumelden und versuchen mitzuhelfen
die Gegend um letusch gehört zu
denjenigen in Slowenien die am stärksten
von der Flut betroffen sind an vielen
hängen drohen außerdem noch weitere
Erdrutsche so feucht ist der Boden ja
was hier passiert ist eine echte
Katastrophe sagt der Bürgermeister viele
Leute sind obdachlos unsere Priorität
ist die Stromversorgung und das
Trinkwasser wieder anzuschließen
noch immer Punkte Zivilschutz Wasser aus
den Gärten und den Häusern vor allem den
schnellen Warnungen und den schnellen
Eingreifen von Feuerwehr und
Zivilschutzes zu verdanken dass es in
dieser Flutkatastrophe bisher nicht mehr
als sechs Todesopfer gab seit vier Tagen
im Einsatz ist ihnen die Müdigkeit ins
Gesicht geschrieben
wir sind hier weil uns sowas hätte auch
passieren können es geht um Solidarität
man weiß doch nie was einem zustößt im
Leben
neben der Hilfe für diejenigen die ihr
Haus verloren haben hat die Regierung
alle Kräfte zusammengezogen um auch die
in frastruktur wieder in Gang zu
bekommen Rücken Straßen Trinkwasser und
Stromversorgung jede verfügbare Maschine
ist im Einsatz was sie in Slowenien
neben der angelaufenen internationalen
Unterstützung jetzt genauso zählt die
große Hilfsbereitschaft der freiwilligen
ich bin nur froh dass meiner Mutter
nichts passiert ist und dass meine
Verwandten hier sind um zu helfen
die Regierung hat kommenden Montag
landesweit zum solidaritätstag erklärt
alle bekommen frei um den Flutopfern zu
helfen
für den Klimaschutz war es eine eher
gute Nachricht das in Brasilien nicht
mehr einen regelrechter Klimawandel
leugnen Präsidentenpalast sitzt der
Nationalist bolzenaru hatte sich jeder
Einmischung verbieten und die Wälder des
Amazonas massiv Abholzen lassen sein
Nachfolger Lula hingegen verspricht bis
2030 die Abholzung sogar ganz zu beenden
ob das so gelingen kann ist fraglich
aber immerhin unternimmt die neue
Regierung einiges um gegen illegale
Rodungen vorzugehen und Luder sucht
Verbündete wie jetzt beim großen
amazonasgipfel der Anrainerstaaten in
bellen insgesamt leben in der Region
über 50 Millionen Menschen ihre
unterschiedlichen Interessen und
wirtschaftlichen Bedürfnisse mit dem
naturschutzen Einklang zu bringen das
wird nur in Verbund gehen und mit neuen
Ideen
wie sich ruggerio Bahia hier tief im
Regenwald zurechtfindet bleibt uns ein
Rätsel aber rosierio weiß genau wonach
er sucht und warum er sein Leben dieser
Schlaufe anvertraut
auf mindestens 50 Palmen klettert er
jeden Tag um oben in der Krone eine
gefragte Beere zu ernten Assi
die bittere wäre ist nahrhaft und gesund
ein Grundnahrungsmittel des Regenwaldes
bedeutet viel für mich es ist das
Produkt von hier aus unserer Region dass
uns ernährt und uns ein Einkommen
sichert
auch außerhalb von rogeriusdorf wächst
die Nachfrage nach hassai wegen der
Vielfalt ihrer Nährstoffe will die Beere
als sogenanntes Superfood und damit ist
assai nicht nur eine Chance für die
regionale Wirtschaft sondern für den
Regenwald insgesamt denn am besten
wächst assai wo der Wald noch intakt ist
Profit ohne Abholzung ist möglich sagt
der Leiter der örtlichen kooperativ
gibt das ist die Grundlage für unser
Einkommen in drei bis vier Jahren können
wir vom Ertrag dieser Pflanzen leben
der Regenwald ist ihr Gewächshaus in dem
sie ernten und wieder anpflanzen neben
assai auch zahlreiche andere regionale
Arten Restaurants Reformhäuser
Kosmetikkonzerne in aller Welt entdecken
mehr und mehr die einzigartigen Früchte
des Regenwaldes
gib mehr als 60 Produkte aus dem
Amazonas die für den Export geeignet und
mit Waldschutz vereinbar sind assai
anderes Obst Fisch es ist wichtig diese
Produktionsketten zu stärken
und andere Früchte des Waldes
exportieren zu können müssen sie
getrocknet werden dafür haben sie hier
im Dorf eigens eine Fabrik gebaut doch
bis heute hat es der Stromversorger
versäumt den Anschluss zu legen
16 Stunden dauert die Fahrt mit der
Fähre in die nächste Großstadt willing
die langen Transportwege sind auch eine
Herausforderung die es zu meistern gilt
will man den Wald nachhaltig nutzen
dort in Belang hat die brasilianische
Regierung zum Regenwald Gipfel geladen
um eine gemeinsame Strategie zu
entwickeln Waldschutz und
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung miteinander
zu verbinden
wir müssen Umweltschutz und soziale
Inklusion im Einklang bringen dazu
gehören die Förderung von Wissenschaft
technologie-
ein ehrgeiziges Ziel denn es gilt viele
Interessen zu vereinen und gerade für
die Bewohner des Regenwaldes steht viel
auf dem Spiel
unweit des Kongresszentrums laden Sie
assai aus frisch aus dem Wald aber nur
aus der Nähe das assay aus dem Dorf das
wir besucht haben würde die lange
Überfahrt nicht überstehen solange es in
der dortigen Fabrik keinen Strom gibt
und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
mit der Fußball-WM ja da gab es jetzt
die letzten beiden Achtelfinale
kolumbien hat 1:0 gegen Jamaika gewonnen
und damit zum ersten Mal ein
WM-Viertelfinale erreicht in dem steht
auf Frankreich durch ein 4:0 gegen
Marokko
Frankreich findet früh seinen Rhythmus
dominiert das Geschehen
mit perfekter Flanke auf Diani das 1:0
in der 15 Minuten nur fünf Minuten
später die ja nie diesmal als
vorbereiterin mit dem Blick für Kenza
Dali der Favorit für 2:0 und legt direkt
nach
Marokko ist El Chat wird von dir
geblockte
Null nach 23 Minuten
ein Debakel droht doch Marokko
stabilisiert sich nur noch ein Treffer
für le bleu erneut lesso mehr zum 4:0
Frankreich souverän im Viertelfinale
trifft auf Gastgeber Australien
[Applaus]
am Samstag live im ZDF und alle WM
Spiele finden Sie bei uns auch kurz
gefasst online unter ZDF heute.de
bei der para Bahnrad-WM in Glasgow hat
die deutsche Meike Hausberger
überraschend die Goldmedaille im scratch
der stadtklasse C2 gewonnen bislang
stehen bei dieser WM sechs Medaillen auf
dem Konto der deutschen para Radsportler
auch im straßenzeit Fahren der rad-wm
hat sich das deutsche Team eine Medaille
gesichert die Mixed Staffel aus drei
Männern und drei Frauen belegte den
dritten Platz zur Halbzeit hatten die
deutschen Männer die viertbeste Zeit
vorgelegt dann gelang es den Frauen noch
einen Platz nach vorne zu fahren den
Titel holte sich wie im Jahr zuvor die
Schweiz Silber geht an Frankreich
begonnen haben wir die Sendung ja mit
der Halbleiterindustrie und Mikrochips
die ja wirklich überall drinstecken auch
Touchscreen Gesichtserkennung und
ähnliches ist gar nicht denkbar ohne
Halbleiter und natürlich auch keine
künstliche Intelligenz mit der wir uns
jetzt zum Schluss noch mal befassen und
zwar in einem kulturpolitischen
Zusammenhang wenn KI Texte oder Videos
produziert wem gehört dann eigentlich
das Urheberrecht und wenn es Kunstwerke
sind ist die KI dann die Künstlerin
in den USA beschäftigt man sich mit
solchen Fragen bereits ziemlich intensiv
berichtet MRT wissen
wenn David young neue Kunst macht
inspirierte ihn schon mal die Natur und
der hört sich erstmal so an als habe er
mit künstlicher Intelligenz nichts am
Hut
[Musik]
diese neuen Systeme sind eigentlich so
was wie betrug wenn du mogeln willst
okay aber es ist trotzdem betrug jetzt
und doch experimentiert David mit
künstlicher Intelligenz gefüttert mit
pusteblumenfotos zum Beispiel die KI
produziert dann Variationen mathematisch
also nicht nach ästhetischen oder
emotionalen Kriterien trotzdem kann die
KI nach dem Befehl die amerikanische
Flagge in Fragmente zu zerlegen auf
einmal emotionale Wirklichkeit abbilden
in diesem so zerrissenen Land
die Ergebnisse reflektieren das Chaos
das in unserer Demokratie wächst durch
die Unwahrheiten Voreingenommenheiten
und Feindseligkeiten der Menschen
sieht KI als bedro deshalb hat sich die
Künstlerin einer Sammelklage
angeschlossen ihre Arbeiten sollen nicht
als Datensätze dienen mit denen
Maschinen dann künstliche Kunst
produzieren
kis-software kann heute schon mit
wenigen Angaben Bilder erschaffen
basierend auf eingefütterten Werken von
realen Künstlern selbst die
us-urheberrechtsbehörde ringt mit den
Ergebnissen bei einem komplett von KI
erstellten Comicbuch gewährte sie der
Herstellerin zunächst das Urheberrecht
und zog es dann doch wieder zurück
solche Produkte Schaden ihrer Kunst
meint der Blick
wollen die sich vordrängeln waren die
frustriert weil ihre Kunst nicht ankam
ich sehe die sogenannten ki-künstler als
möchtegern Künstler die nicht gut genug
waren
traditionelle Handarbeit ist die Kunst
von Philipp Linder er ist ein Fan von
neuester Technologie deshalb hat er
nichts gegen Kollegen die KI als
Werkzeug einsetzen
Kunst ist der Ausdruck menschlicher
Emotionen mit Hilfe geschickter
Fertigkeiten das ist eine gute
Definition und dann ist KI in vielerlei
Hinsicht so etwas wie ein schicker
Pinsel
ihn faszinieren die Möglichkeiten aber
einfach nur ein tippen mach ein Bild im
Stil von Monet und übertrage das dann in
die Moderne in der eine Journalistin
eine Künstlerin interviewt das sei noch
kein Kunstwerk
wenn du ein Musiker bist ein Maler
Tänzer was auch immer dann holst du dir
ja von irgendwoher Inspiration am
wahrscheinlichsten von anderer Kunst das
ist Teil deines künstlerischen Prozesses
deshalb ist der Schlüssel doch dass der
Künstler sein Werk so weit
unterscheidbar macht dass er es als ein
Original bezeichnen kann
genau darin liegt die Chance für
kreative Menschen etwas zu schaffen was
neues nicht nur zurückschauen sondern
das zu suchen was der menschlichste
Ausdruck ist in dieser Welt jenseits von
künstlicher Intelligenz
es ist der Aufruf sich von der
Wirklichkeit zu neuem inspirieren zu
lassen statt sich der künstlichen Kunst
einfach zu ergeben
ob KI irgendwann auch unser
Beziehungsleben verändern wird wer auch
mal ein interessantes Thema um
ungewöhnliche Beziehungen geht es gleich
in der Reportage Reihe 37 Grad Beziehung
die unkonventionell sind aber noch
analog
und uns beide gibt es dann morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht breitet sich
Regen vor allen Dingen über die Mitte
Deutschlands aus und an der Ostsee sind
noch Schauer und Gewitter bei
stürmischem Westwind unterwegs die
Temperaturen sinken auf 15 Grad an der
Nordsee und am Oberrhein und bis 8 Grad
am Alpenrand morgen Vormittag bleibt es
in Süddeutschland trüb da fällt häufig
noch Regen im Norden werden sie häufiger
schon die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen an
der Ostsee gibt's Schauer und Gewitter
am Nachmittag verabschieden die sich
dann mehr und mehr ostwärts und dann
kommt auch in Süddeutschland häufiger
die Sonne zum Zuge und prompt steigen
dort die Temperaturen am Oberrhein bis
25 Grad 17 Grad sind es an der Ostsee
und dann wird es von Tag zu Tag immer
wärmer am Samstag kommt die Wärme dann
auch an der Küste an bei 20 bis 23 Grad
der freundlichste Tag dieser Woche wird
eindeutig der Freitag da gibt's viel
Sonnenschein bei 20 bis 30 Grad das
Wochenende bleibt warm wird aber doch
wechselhafter es ist Profil zur Zeit
auch die Saison der tropischen
wirbelstürmer auf dem Atlantik ist es
zur Zeit relativ ruhig nicht so auf dem
Pazifik hier südlich von Hawaii gibt es
ein Hurrikan der zweithöchsten Kategorie
Dora heißt der und zwei weitere
Tropenstürme sind Richtung Asien
unterwegs der eine der beschäftigt uns
schon seit zwei Wochen dass es Kanun der
zieht jetzt Richtung Korea und wird dort
auch einige Menschen beeinflussen was
mit dem Tropensturm Land passiert ist
noch nicht so ganz klar vielleicht kann
er vor Tokyo noch ostwärts abziehen wir
behalten dass wir sie im Auge guten
Abend